The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANDREW LO: Actually, at
the end of class last time,
we were talking about what
happened with the stock
prices of those
four companies that
were engaged in manufacturing
parts for the space shuttle.
And I didn't realize
this, but apparently,
in some of your
other classes, I've
been told that you actually
did a case on Morton Thiokol,
and the fact that there were
some interesting discussions
between the Morton
Thiokol and NASA
engineers about
whether to launch.
And that, in fact, when
you just look at it
from the perspective
of the data,
it would not have made sense
to go ahead with the launch.
Well, the point about
efficient markets
is that, while it may not be
immediately apparent as to what
all of the inputs are for
coming up with a bottom line
price for an asset, the fact is
that enormous, enormous amounts
of information are collected,
collated, analyzed,
and ultimately
reflected in the price,
to the point where, after
a six month investigation,
it was determined that
Morton Thiokol was
at fault for the explosion.
But, in fact, within hours after
the crash and literally minutes
we see that the
Morton Thiokol stock
price was the one hit hardest.
And even when you control
for other factors like size
and industry effects, you
still have a pretty significant
finger pointed at Morton Thiokol
purely from the stock market.
In a nutshell, this is what
efficient markets is about.
And for the longest
time that is really
what academic finance
taught, and what
was the basis for virtually
everything that we do.
So, in fact, all the
material that we've
covered in this course
really assumes and requires
that markets work well.
That markets reflect all
available information.
Because obviously if it
didn't, then when I tell you,
go look at the market, I'm
telling you to waste your time,
right?
Because why would
you consult something
that really didn't contain
some significant informational
advantages?
That's the good news.
That's the positive side
of efficient markets.
Over the last 15,
20 years, there
have been more
and more criticism
leveled against this hypothesis
of efficient markets.
And the most easy, the most
obvious and easiest way
to make that point,
is with a joke
that you might have
heard about economists.
Two economists walking
down the street.
One of them sees a $100
bill lying on the ground
and starts to pick it up when
the other economist says, "Oh,
don't bother picking it up."
And then the first economist
says, "Well, why not?"
The second economist
says, "Well,
if that were a real,
genuine $100 bill,
someone would have
already taken it,
so it must be a counterfeit."
Now you laugh at that.
But that's exactly what
efficient market says.
It says that you can't
make any money in markets
because, if you could, someone
would have already done it.
Markets are so competitive
that, in fact, you
can't make any money.
And after awhile, people
started asking questions
about this hypothesis.
In particular, they would
ask the question, well,
if nobody can make
any money, then why
does anybody bother going
into financial markets?
If nobody makes any
money, then who's
the folks out there that
is gathering information
to make markets efficient?
So first of all, there's
a bit of a Zen paradox.
And we'll talk about that Zen
paradox a little bit later on.
But the more
substantial criticisms
have to do with the fact that
this presumption of efficiency
requires rationality.
In particular, it requires
that market participants
behave the way that economists
would argue that they behave.
So all of you are very
gracious in not arguing with me
that you would all want to
hold the tangency portfolio.
Now, you could have asked
me at that time, well,
why would I want to hold
the tangency portfolio?
I may happen to enjoy holding
a small subset of stocks
that I know, and love, and
have a particular emotional
attachment to.
But you probably recognize
that that wasn't where
the class was going, so you were
very gracious in not raising
that as an issue, even though,
in your heart of hearts,
you might really prefer that.
You might simply want to hold
a few stocks that you know,
and enjoy, and believe in,
and so on and so forth.
Well, that's an example of an
irrationality from the point
of view of the economist.
And in a minute, I'm
going to actually call
into question what we mean
by rationality altogether.
So by the end of
this lecture, I'm
going to make a fairly
strong prediction.
I'm going to predict
that what I'm
going to tell you in the
next hour and 15 minutes
will change your
lives permanently.
That's a tall order.
But you'll let me know.
In five or 10 years, I want you
to write me back and tell me
whether or not I'm right.
I think I am right,
because I'm going
to change the way all of you
look at rationality completely.
And actually we're
going to do this
in the context of
your own behavior.
All right?
So let me tell you where
we're going with this.
Behavioral finance,
the alternative
to market efficiency, says that
market participants are simply
irrational.
They don't make
decisions the way
that economists would
presuppose that they do.
In particular, they suffer
from all sorts of biases,
and they're listed here.
Loss aversion,
anchoring, framing.
Overconfidence.
Overreaction.
Herding.
Mental accounting.
And so on.
And some of you,
I think, may have
come across these in
some of the other courses
that you've taken.
If you ever take an
experimental psychology course,
you would actually see
these kinds of examples
in pretty intimate detail.
When you look down this list,
and you take seriously what
the psychologists
are telling us,
you would conclude
that the human animal
is among the stupidest
creatures on earth
because we engage in all
of these kinds of biases.
And I want to go
through a few examples.
Some of you may have
already seen this
because I actually
gave these examples
in my introductory
talk on finance.
And if you have, we're going to
go through it pretty quickly.
But if you haven't, I think
you'll be kind of surprised
by some of the outcomes.
So the loss aversion
example is one
that I did give in my
introductory lecture.
How many people have seen
this or remember this?
OK.
So I'm going to go through
this pretty quickly.
This is an example where clearly
most people, when they're
confronted with a choice of a
certain gain versus a riskier
alternative that might
have even bigger gains
but might also entail
gaining nothing,
that most everybody would pick
choice A over B, as most of you
did when we ran this example at
the beginning of the semester.
So even though B has a higher
expected value, more risk,
more expected return, like
the CAPM says you should have,
nevertheless, most of you
as a personal preference
would pick the less
risky alternative, A.
Now, when you're
confronted with losses,
as you recall from the
example, most of you
picked not the sure
loss but rather
the gamble that actually might
cause you to lose even more
but might also allow
you to get back to even.
So the reason that these two
choices are so interesting
is that, in the first
case of A versus B,
you picked the less risky
alternative because you are
being confronted with gains.
But in this case, when you're
being confronted with two
losses, instead of being
consistent and picking the less
risky alternative-- which, by
the way, is the sure loss C--
virtually all of you
picked the gamble.
You're willing to
take more risk when
it comes to losses than you
are when it comes to gains.
That's an asymmetry
that frankly doesn't
jibe with modern
financial theory,
with utility maximization,
with efficient markets.
So the reason that these
two sets of choices
are so interesting when
juxtaposed together
is that the choices that most
of you did pick, A and D,
was actually strictly dominated
by the choices that most of you
did not pick, which is C and
B. When you combine these two,
you can show that B
and C is exactly equal
to the most popular choices,
A and D, plus $10,000 cash.
So you guys left $10,000
lying on the sidewalk.
And that's clearly
not efficient.
Well, it turns out that there is
a reason for this kind of bias,
and it's hardwired
into all of you.
And I'm going to tell you
what that is in a few minutes,
after I go through just a
couple of other examples
to make sure that
we all understand
the limitations of what we
consider to be rational,
economic decision-making.
Any questions
about this example?
This is called loss aversion.
This is an example
that was first
proposed by two psychologists,
Kahneman and Tversky,
and for which Kahneman won
the Nobel Prize in economics
a couple of years ago.
Tversky would have won it
as well, had he been alive,
but he died a few years before.
And what's interesting
about the fact
that Kahneman won
the Nobel Prize is
that he's not an economist,
he's a psychologist.
And so, in a way, maybe
the Nobel Memorial Prize
in Economics was trying
to signal to the economics
profession that they ought
to take these kind of things
more seriously.
OK.
This is the second
example that I
gave in that
introductory lecture
on drawing balls out of an urn.
How many people still
remember this example?
No?
OK, so let me go through this
in a little bit more detail
because this is
directly relevant
to the current financial
crisis that we're facing.
Those of you who've ever taken
an undergraduate statistics
course, you'll remember
the bane of your existence
during that semester.
It was the prototypical
urn example, right?
Drawing balls out of an urn.
I hated those examples.
They're a real pain in the neck.
So I'm going to
give you one now.
But this one is not
as bad as the others
that you might have come across.
I want you to imagine
an urn that I have
where I've got 100 balls.
And 50 of those balls
are colored red,
the other 50 are colored black.
They're otherwise identical.
And you and I, we're
going to play a game.
And here's the game.
You pick a color, red or black.
Don't tell me what it is.
Write it down on
a piece of paper.
And then I'm going to draw
a ball out of this urn.
And if the ball that
I draw is your color,
I'm going to pay you $10,000.
And if it's not, I'm
going to pay you nothing.
OK?
That's the game.
And we're going to
do this exactly once.
Play this game once.
I wish we could do
this in reality.
But the prize is a
little bit higher
than what our dean is willing
to let me gamble with.
But let's imagine we're
going to do this for real.
OK?
So I want you to tell
me, first of all,
how many people would be willing
to play this game with me
for $1?
In other words, you pay me
$1 and we'll play this--
Yeah, OK.
Good.
How about $1,000?
$2,000?
$3,000?
$4,000?
$4,500?
$4,999?
$5,010?
OK.
So I still had a few
hands up at $4,999.
Nobody wants to play
this with me for $5,010,
presumably because?
Louis?
AUDIENCE: So if you
asked the question,
how many people would sit
down at a blackjack table--
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or a roulette wheel--
AUDIENCE: I think people
would raise their hand.
ANDREW LO: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: But they
won't pay $5,010
to play this game of red black?
ANDREW LO: Well, that's a
different question though,
right?
AUDIENCE: This is
a roulette wheel.
ANDREW LO: Well, but it's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
house money.
ANDREW LO: --not a
roulette wheel though.
It's a different game.
It's an urn with 50
balls red and 50 black.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ANDREW LO: I mean,
you know, I have
to tell you that a
roulette wheel happens
to be more entertaining.
You know, you see the
little ball rolling around,
and it's a different game.
All right, I want to come
back to this in a minute.
But let's get back to the price.
I established the
price of $5,000.
And, not surprisingly,
all of you
extremely numerate
MIT students, you
figured out that the expected
value is $5,000, right?
And so that's what you bid.
OK.
Now before I go on, let me
ask you one other question.
Do you have a preference
for which color you'd pick?
No preference?
You sure?
Why not?
No preference?
AUDIENCE: It's 50%.
ANDREW LO: It's
50/50, that's right.
So there's no
reason that you have
a preference one or the other.
However, I should
just let you know
that in populations where
they do this kind of survey,
there is a slight
preference for the color red
in the population.
It's kind of interesting.
But, you know, all
right, fine, 50/50.
You understand the game.
There's no preference.
OK, now, we're going to
play the exact same game
except with urn B. Urn
B is identical to urn
A in every respect except
that, in this case,
I'm not going to tell
you the proportion.
There could be
50/50 red and black,
but it could be 40/60, or
70/30, or 85/15, or 100/0.
I will promise you that
there are exactly 100 balls
and there are, at most, two
colors, red and/or black,
but beyond that, I will
not tell you anything.
And now we're going to
play the exact same game.
OK?
So the question is,
first of all, what color
would you prefer?
Any of you have any
particular preference here?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: Red.
ANDREW LO: Red.
You'd prefer red?
OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Go for
black because you know
that most people prefer red.
ANDREW LO: Well, no, I didn't
say most people prefer red.
I said there was a slight
preference for red,
and, Ingrid, you seem to
fall into that category.
And so you'd prefer
black instead.
All right.
Well, we're going to come
back to the color later on.
But now let me ask
you, how much would you
pay to play this game with me?
Everything else is the same.
$10,000 prize if you get
the color that I pick.
All right?
AUDIENCE: Do we trust you?
ANDREW LO: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Can we trust you?
ANDREW LO: I don't know.
Do you?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ANDREW LO: Well, first of
all, what is there to trust?
AUDIENCE: Is there
really a hundred?
ANDREW LO: I, yes,
that I will guarantee.
So after the fact, that we will
verify that there is exactly
100 balls and it
will be, at most,
two colors, red and/or
black, and that's it.
No other elements
will be introduced.
OK?
So that's perfectly verifiable,
and we will verify that
after the fact,
that all prices are
contingent upon
that verification.
But that's the extent to
which you need to trust me.
If you're asking
whether or not I'm
the one that's picking the
distribution, then, yes, I am.
I'm picking the distribution.
But I don't
communicate with you,
and you don't communicate
with me ahead of time,
other than what I know
about you in this class
and over the last semester.
OK?
So now, let's
figure out how much
this will draw in
terms of the price.
How many people will be willing
to play this game with me
once for $1?
$1,000?
$2,000?
$3,000?
$4,000?
$4,999?
$5,010?
OK.
So it's about the--
You'd pay more?
You'd pay more to play this
game than the one before?
I'm going to come back
to that in a minute.
That's worth exploring.
But before I get back
to Davide, Justin,
you were willing to
pay the same for both.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Well,
because the proportion
doesn't matter because
you pick your color,
so it's kind of
out of your hands.
You know it's either one
color or the other color.
You know the
proportion's already
been decided upon
so it should be
the same as the previous game.
ANDREW LO: OK, so you think
that the odds are the same
in this case as before?
Even though I'm the one
that picks the odds?
AUDIENCE: When you
pick it beforehand
and, I guess if it was random--
ANDREW LO: Well, no, no, no.
It's exactly what
I just told you.
I get to pick the odds so,
unless you consider me random--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but we
still get to pick the ball--
ANDREW LO: You get
to pick the ball.
You have to pick the
color, I pick the ball.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I still
think it's about 50/50.
ANDREW LO: 50/50.
OK.
Mike?
AUDIENCE: Do you pick the odds
after we tell you our thoughts?
ANDREW LO: No, it's clearly not.
Yeah.
No, no.
That's a good point.
And, no, we won't
cheat, in the sense
that I will not pick the
distribution after you tell me
what your color is.
OK.
Dannon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I
mean, you really don't know
the probability, so--
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You really need
to have one black ball?
Since you're drawing,
you know, one more person
who has to match the color.
Then you have another
99 that are left.
So your probability's are
really high at that point.
Unless you're very unlucky,
with that very first ball
as being black, then--
So, but it could go either way.
ANDREW LO: OK.
So I'm-- So what's
the bottom line?
Do you think it's the same
as before, or it's different?
Would you bid the same amount
to play this game with me?
AUDIENCE: I ended up
bidding the same amount.
ANDREW LO: You did?
OK.
Anybody disagree with that?
Anybody that would
not pay the same?
A lot of you didn't
pay the same.
Yeah, Jen?
AUDIENCE: Well, I would just
calculate that the worst
outcome here is worse.
It's like $100.
ANDREW LO: Yeah, that's right.
AUDIENCE: I would pay $100.
ANDREW LO: That is
the worst outcome.
I mean, if you pick red, I could
have 100 black balls in there,
and then you're going
to lose, no matter what.
AUDIENCE: But that's
also the best.
Yeah.
Pick black.
Because it's-- [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: That's true, yes.
If you look at it
the other way, it's
the best case if you
did the opposite.
Hmm.
So what do we make of that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think
basically it's,
the laws of standard
probability are the same.
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because, in
this case, the probability
is you all being able
to pick the right ball.
And that's 50/50.
The right color, right?
ANDREW LO: Is it?
Is it 50/50 though?
That's the question.
Yeah.
I'm picking the distribution,
you're picking the ball, right?
Yeah, Davide?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure
I understand exactly.
So--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ANDREW LO: That would
explain, certainly.
Sure.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Say the real
proportion is 50/50,
I would pay you $5,000.
ANDREW LO: Sure.
AUDIENCE: If the real
proportion is zero,
I wouldn't pay you any more.
If the real proportion is one,
ANDREW LO: Yeah, that's right.
Sure.
If you knew that
this was-- if you
had an insider's view of
what the proportion is,
you might pay more.
AUDIENCE: So, in other words,
I would pay more than $5,000.
ANDREW LO: OK, but do you
think you know something then?
AUDIENCE: No, but
I would say that I
would pay more than $5,000.
ANDREW LO: Why?
Why?
Only if you had
more information.
But do you?
Do you think you have
more information?
AUDIENCE: Even if
it's less than 50/50,
then I would pay
more than $5,000.
ANDREW LO: But what if
it's more than 50/50?
What if it's more
than, in other words,
what if it's 60/40 against you,
as opposed to 40/60 with you?
AUDIENCE: Because at 60/40--
I mean, it's like--
as if it were 100/0,
then I would be winning.
Sure.
ANDREW LO: That
depends on your color.
It depends on your color.
Yeah, David?
AUDIENCE: If there's no
expectation that you're biased,
you can't make that expectation
and the expectation of how
much you could get is the same.
ANDREW LO: OK.
AUDIENCE: So if you're going
just on the expectation
of what your bias is--
ANDREW LO: Right.
Well, so you guys have seen
me over the last 12 weeks.
You know what my biases are.
In this case, I've
already told you
that I have some information.
Right?
That people, on average,
prefer red a little bit more
than black.
So actually, you have
that piece of information.
What would you do with it?
Does that tell you anything?
AUDIENCE: It tells
us everything.
ANDREW LO: Well, it
does tell you something.
It tells you that I
know that people prefer
red slightly more than black.
But the problem with that
is that you know I know.
And moreover, I know
you know I know,
and you know I know
you know I know.
When you take it back to
its infinite regression,
you know what it comes up to?
50/50.
It turns out that,
mathematically,
the odds for this
game are literally
identical to the odds
of the previous game.
But it's also the case that
when you take these two urns
and you auction them
off to the public,
there is a very, very
significant discount
in what people will pay for urn
B. And we saw this in class.
A lot fewer of you
raised your hands
we were going to $3,000,
$4,000, and $4,999.
And you know why?
When you ask people,
why is it that you
would pay less for this
urn than the previous one,
they'll tell you very plainly
it's because, in this case,
I don't know what the odds are.
I know what the odds are
in the previous case,
but I don't know what kind
of risks I'm dealing with.
In most dictionaries
and thesauruses,
risk and uncertainty
are considered synonyms.
But in fact, we see here that,
from a decision-making point
of view, when there is
uncertainty about your risk,
you tend to shy away from
that because I don't know
what I'm dealing with here.
Now there is one
simple mechanism
by which all of you in this
room could make it impossible
for me to somehow
strategically pick the worst
distribution against you.
Anybody tell me what
that algorithm is?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you
just flipped a coin
to decide what color you pick?
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
If Brian flips his coin, not
my coin, if you take your coin
and flip it and pick red or
black based upon the outcome,
there's no way I could
possibly do anything
to disadvantage you.
Now, that's a real interesting
conclusion, isn't it?
Because what that's
telling you is
that by injecting
uncertainty into a system,
you might actually make it
more preferable, more fair,
by adding randomness in there.
And yet when you tell
people that, they say,
well, you know that sounds
great, I still don't want this.
Because I don't want to
deal with the uncertainty.
And that's hardwired.
We as human beings shy
away from the unknown.
OK, now, take this
example and apply it
to a non-financial
corporation that
has toxic assets as part
of its balance sheet
where you have no idea what the
market value is, because there
is no market, because
it's not trading.
Because you don't know how
to evaluate the security
because it contains too many
parts that you can't figure out
what the legal,
never mind financial,
ramifications are
for those assets.
And you can understand now why
people say, oh, wait a minute,
I don't want to play.
I don't I don't care
what it's worth.
I don't want to know.
I don't want to deal
with it because I
can't evaluate the risk.
That's what's happening
in spades today.
[? Shlomi? ?]
AUDIENCE: In the
second game, you
said that the people preferred
to pay less because they don't
want to go with uncertainty.
ANDREW LO: The uncertainty
about the risk.
AUDIENCE: But uncertainty
about the risk is unimportant.
ANDREW LO: That's right.
AUDIENCE: They don't
understand the game.
This is the reason why
they prefer to [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW LO: Well, let
me put it this way.
All of you here, I think,
are pretty sophisticated.
All of you, by the way,
understand the mathematics
of this game, I believe.
Right?
There's not that
many moving parts.
If we were to do an
anonymous survey where
I forced you to play with me--
So, in other words,
I deducted $5,000
from your payroll, so
you're playing with me,
no matter whether
you like it or not.
You just paid $5,000.
But I did let you choose whether
you play with urn A or urn B.
I bet you the result,
even in as sophisticated
an audience as this, is that the
vast majority would pick urn A,
not urn B. You don't
have to raise your hands.
I won't put you on the spot.
But my guess is that most
of you, if not all of you,
would end up picking urn A
simply because you then can
evaluate the uncertainty,
whereas with B, you can't.
So you're right that,
mathematically, they're
the same.
But the fact is that we
shy away from anything
we don't understand, and
so what that suggests
is that there are
layers of risk.
In fact, there was an
economist many years ago
by the name of Frank
Knight who was trying
to explain how it was that
certain people in the economy
were so much richer than others.
In fact, he was trying to
explain the great wealth
of the big mega industrialists.
These are the folks like
Pierpont Morgan who was worth,
at that time, $100
million, which
was an extraordinary
amount of wealth.
The modern day version
today is Bill Gates.
The question is,
should Bill Gates
be worth $40 billion
or $50 billion?
Does that make sense?
I mean, is he really
that much more valuable
in any way than any of us?
Why should somebody like that
be worth so much more money?
And Frank Knight
struggled with this
because he didn't
understand how,
from an economic perspective,
you could justify it.
And he finally came up with
the following hypothesis
or proposal for why
these entrepreneurs
make so much money.
It's because they are taking
on a kind of randomness that
is not quantifiable.
In other words, there's
two kinds of randomness
in Frank Knight's perspective.
One is risk.
Risk is quantifiable.
For example, mortality rates.
I don't know how many of you
have looked at life insurance
policies.
But if you have, as I did when
I first had my first child,
I decided to learn a little
bit about life insurance,
and read mortality tables, and
looked at life expectancies,
and so on.
And I found it
enormously depressing
because it turns
out that, if you
tell me 15 facts about your
life, with those 15 facts
I can actually
pinpoint your life
expectancy to within
plus or minus 5 years,
with an enormous
degree of accuracy.
And, as far as I'm concerned,
that's much more information
than I need.
I don't need to know
when I'm going to die.
Think about it.
Actually, as economists
we always say,
the more information
you have, the better.
Do you really believe that?
Do you want to know when
you're going to die?
If I had that
information, would you
want me to tell you when
you're going to die?
The specific day and time?
Would you like to know?
Think about that.
Well, it turns out with
these mortality tables,
whether or not
you've ever smoked,
do you drink, what kind of car
do you drive, have you ever
had an accident?
There is these 15
or 20 questions
that, once you answer them,
you get put into a box.
And that box has a life
expectancy that ends up
being pretty darned accurate.
Now, the point of this is that
the life insurance business
is not currently
a growth business.
I don't think
anybody here is dying
to graduate from Sloan to
start a life insurance company.
Why is that?
It's because there's not
that much profit left,
given that it's relatively
well understood how
to forecast mortality rates.
And once you forecast them,
you can price the insurance
in such a way that you'll
be slightly profitable,
and that's pretty much
all you're going to do.
So the profit opportunities
for the kinds of randomness
that you can define very
precisely, like mortality
tables, or property
and casualty insurance,
there's not a lot of
profit in that anymore.
Maybe for the first person
who did it, yes, there was.
But by that time,
at that time, there
wasn't a lot of data on this.
OK.
So Knight said
that you don't get
rewarded with untold sums of
wealth for taking on risk.
What you get rewarded for
with untold sums of wealth
is for taking on uncertainty.
Uncertainty is what Frank
Knight called the risk
that nobody can parameterize.
So, nanotechnology.
Who the heck knows whether or
not that's going to pay off?
We don't even know what that
is, or whether it's really
a business.
That kind of uncertainty, if
you're willing to take that on,
then there are those
who will make literally
billions of dollars.
And so the profits that
economists would argue
have to be in
equilibrium, zero, right?
Zero profit condition
is typically
what an economic
equilibrium consists of.
Zero profit only
applies to the risks
that can be parameterized,
that can be well understood.
And the point is that the
human tendency is to shy away
from the uncertainties of life.
We don't like things
we don't understand,
and we will shrink from those.
So if you are wired
in a different way
to be willing to take
those kinds of risks,
you're going to get paid
huge sums of money for that.
Ike?
AUDIENCE: In terms of the
zero sum math game, what about
the silence of the cemetery?
That Bill Gates is offset by
the thousands of entrepenuers
who've failed and
are worth nothing?
So, on average,
they're all mortal.
ANDREW LO: Well, that may be
true that, on average, it all
works out.
But the point is that why do
you have such a huge disparity
for certain kinds of
randomness whereas,
for other kinds of randomness,
you have a nice bell curve?
In other words, why
do you have this kind
of tail risk going on?
The tail risk that
you're talking about?
The silence of the cemeteries.
The fact that, for
every one Bill Gates,
you've got several million
failed entrepreneurs,
is because people are taking
on the kind of randomness
that nobody knows
how to quantify.
That's the argument.
So it's consistent
with that perspective.
OK?
So that's why VCs
and entrepreneurs--
those of you who want
to do your start-ups,
I wish you great success.
And in this classroom, I will
bet that at least one of you
will be a billionaire
in 15 years.
And I want to get to know you
very well between now and then.
But the downside, which
all of you should know,
the downside is that for the
rest of the entrepreneurs that
don't make a billion
dollars, you'll make nothing.
Zero.
You'll lose everything.
Now, that's a
reasonable trade-off
if your particular
psychological makeup
enjoys that kind of a thrill.
But it's not for
everybody, and that's
why people get paid
what they get paid.
Right?
So there is some logic
to this kind of puzzle.
By the way, this
particular example
was developed also
by a psychologist
by the name of Ellsberg.
And it's called the
Ellsberg paradox
because this is a
situation where,
despite the fact that
the odds are the same,
people don't like
the uncertainties.
And to me, and to a lot of
evolutionary biologists,
and neurophysiologists,
this is not surprising.
Because we are hardwired
to stay away from stuff
we don't know because
it's the stuff you
don't know that can kill you.
And from an evolutionary
perspective,
it makes a lot of sense.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I feel like a big part
of what got us in this whole
mess is that [INAUDIBLE]
came unwired--
People actually were chasing
stuff they didn't know
and paying more for it.
ANDREW LO: Well, I think it's
not so much they were chasing
what they didn't
know but rather,
they were chasing stuff that
they thought they knew that,
in fact, they didn't.
So we're going to
come back to that.
Let me hold off on that
for just 15 minutes.
I want to take that head
on when we actually look
at the applications to finance.
Zeke?
AUDIENCE: I think there's
also like an [INAUDIBLE]
version of this as well.
It's because there's not--
there's also not
doing your homework.
Taking on some
uncertainty whereas you
could be taking risk.
ANDREW LO: Sure.
Absolutely.
It's possible that this kind
of risk is not systematic risk.
And there's nothing
that says that you
ought to get compensated for
that, except for the fact that,
if you're talking
about very, very, very
unusual kinds of
technologies, or businesses
that nobody really understands
or is able to take on,
that's where the
multibillion dollar
paydays are going to come from.
It's not going to come from
starting up a news stand,
or setting up another
restaurant, or selling coffee.
Well, coffee, maybe.
Let me take that back because
we have some counter-examples.
But the point is that,
if it's commoditized,
if everybody understands
how to do it,
then the profits ultimately are
going to get bid down to zero.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's also
brought to your attention,
you know, Warren
Buffet's averages
of the normal conventions
of, you know, [INAUDIBLE]..
Then he says [INAUDIBLE]
standard of [INAUDIBLE]..
Right?
So that's, that's a huge, that's
a huge uncertainty factor.
But yet he's still [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW LO: That's right.
He may have made
money in other ways.
Not necessarily by taking risks
that nobody else understood,
but rather by being
early in taking
advantage of opportunities
that other people didn't see.
So there's more than one
way to make a lot of money.
And we'll talk a bit about
that at the end, when
I talk about how evolutionary
pressures ultimately allow
businesses to fail and succeed.
So I'll come back to that.
Any other questions
about the example though?
OK.
So we've got two examples of
irrationalities that all of us
seem to possess.
And the third
example that I give
is one that I think
you have seen,
which is this video
clip of this gorilla.
Right?
This is a clear example
where we are all
hardwired to see certain things
that we are looking to see,
and when we're not
looking for other things,
we don't see them at all.
And this final example I give
because it provides, I think,
incontrovertible evidence
that human cognitive abilities
are limited.
We are not infinitely
rational in the sense
that we can compute,
observe, analyze, forecast,
and remember, an infinite
amount of information.
And so, after all of these
examples, this is why I said,
you must think that the
human animal is the stupidest
creature on earth.
Because we suffer from all
of these behavioral biases.
So the behaviorists
would conclude by saying,
we rest our case.
People are irrational,
therefore how
can you rely on markets for
making any kind of decisions?
Well, the official markets types
have a pretty powerful retort.
And the powerful retort
comes in the form
of what's known as the
Dutch Book theorem.
This is an example
that I also give
to try to illustrate
how it could be that,
even though there are crazy
people some of the time,
and certain people that
are crazy all of the time,
that nevertheless the
smart money will win.
So the example goes like this.
You've got an event A that
we're going to bet on, OK?
And the event is that the
S&P 500 falls by 5% or more
next Monday.
This used to be considered
a pretty extreme event.
Now it's business
as usual, right?
OK.
So let's suppose that you, as
the irrational, behavioral,
psychological creature that
behavioral economists would
argue you are, you have the
following probability belief.
The probability of A is 1/2
and the probability of NOT A
is 3/4.
Now some of you are chuckling
because you would never
have such beliefs, right?
Because the probabilities,
they don't add up to 1.
Well, I guarantee each
and every one of you
if I got you into
a darkly-lit room,
and I asked you a series
of questions over time,
you would ultimately end up
exhibiting biased probabilities
just like this, because
the human cognitive
faculties are not designed to
make correct, probabilistic
inferences.
This is not natural,
that we know
how to make probabilistic,
just judgments.
So let's suppose that
this is what you believe.
Now, what's the problem
with this irrationality?
Well, the problem
is that you would
be willing to take both
of the following two bets.
Bet B1 is a bet where if
A occurs, I pay you $1.
If A doesn't occur,
you pay me $1.
OK?
And the reason you're
willing to take this bet
is because the odds of
A occurring are 1/2.
1/2 means 50/50, and so
you're willing to take
those 50/50 odds with bet B1.
However, because
you also believe
that the probability
of not A is 3/4,
which is one to
three odds, right?
1/4 to 3/4.
One to three odds.
Because of that fact, you're
also willing to take bet B2.
Bet B2 is a bet where I pay
you $1 if A doesn't occur,
but you pay me $3
if A does occur.
And again, the reason you
are willing to do that
is because you believe that the
probability of A not occurring
is 3/4.
Now, if that's the case, you're
willing to take bet B1 and B2,
here's what we're going to do.
I'm going to place $50
on B1 and $25 on B2.
That's the wager that I
want to engage in with you.
If we do that, then
let's see what happens.
If A occurs, I lose my $50 on
B1 but I win three to one odds
on my $25 on B2,
so I win $75 on B2,
so I make $25
profit if A occurs.
If A doesn't occur,
what happens?
Well, if A doesn't occur,
I lose my $25 on B2,
but I make $50 on B1.
I make $25 again.
Heads I win, tails you lose.
No matter what
happens, I make $25,
so I'm going to like this a lot.
And I'm going to keep doing
it, and doing it, and doing it,
until one of two things happens.
Either you run out of money,
or you change your probability
beliefs.
And it turns out that there
is only one set of probability
beliefs for which I cannot
construct this free lunch.
You know that is?
It's when the
probabilities sum to one.
So the point is that there
is a limit to how irrational
you can get.
Because as long as I'm there
to take advantage of you,
I'm simply going to pump money
out of you until you cry,
uncle.
Until you change your beliefs.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are there any examples
of where this has actually
been exploited?
ANDREW LO: Absolutely.
There are tons of examples.
There are tons of
examples of mispricing.
In fact, the example
that I gave you
when we were doing
fixed income arbitrage,
when we had these different
treasury securities
that had different yields for
the very, very same maturities,
and you could solve using
simultaneous linear equations
for the arbitrage.
That is exactly this example.
So there are many, many
examples where this occurs.
And it doesn't last,
typically, because people
get tired of losing money,
and ultimately either they
run out of that money,
or they get wise.
So the idea behind this
argument that efficient markets
folks make is that, sure, people
may be irrational from time
to time, and there may
be some people that
are always irrational,
but as long
as there are smart people
out there, as long as there's
smart money out there,
then it doesn't matter.
Because the probabilities
will sum to one through market
forces.
And so then the question is, how
strong are those market forces?
And I would point to
the current crisis
to tell you that
those market forces,
while if they sound good on
paper and, at a place like MIT,
I promise you that what John
Maynard Keynes said decades ago
is still true.
Which is, the market can stay
irrational much, much longer
than you can stay solvent.
In other words, if you
are the only sane person
in an irrational world, you
are the one with the problem.
Because you can't take
advantage of these opportunities
before ultimately the forces
of irrationality overwhelm you.
At least that's what John
Maynard Keynes thought.
Now, it seems to
suggest then that it's
a question about magnitudes.
In other words, you've
got smart people here,
you've got irrational
people here--
They're going to interact and
may the bigger pocketbook win.
Question is, who's got
the bigger pocketbook?
Who's got the stronger
set of forces?
The irrational guys or the
efficient markets guys?
And before I answer
that question,
or at least propose an
answer to that question,
I need to now beg
your indulgence
for the next 15 or 20
minutes because we're
going to take a little
bit of a detour.
I want to bring in
some evidence from
the cognitive neurosciences
that will speak directly
to this issue of what we
even mean by rationality.
It turns out that what
economists mean by rational
is not what you and I take
to be rational from a daily,
kind of, activities
type of perspective.
So I want to tell you
about some research
in the cognitive
neurosciences that really
changes the way we
think about rationality
and decision-making.
To do that, I'm going to tell
you about a particular case
study that was described
in a book written
by a neuroscientist by the
name of Antonio Damasio.
Damasio is a
clinical neurologist,
meaning that he sees patients
as well as does research.
And about 15 years ago, he wrote
a book titled Descartes' Error,
and in a few minutes
I'll explain to you
where that title comes from.
But in this book, he
describes his experience
in dealing with one
of his patients,
codenamed "Elliot," who
developed a brain tumor that
had to be surgically removed.
And, as you may know, with
these kinds of surgeries,
you've got to remove a
healthy portion of the brain
as well as the
tumor to make sure
that you've got
all of the tumor,
and you don't leave
anything remaining.
So after they took
out this tumor,
and after Eliot recovered
from the surgery,
they gave him a battery of
tests to see whether or not
any of his cognitive
abilities were impaired
because of this surgery.
They gave him a perception
test, memory test, IQ test,
learning ability, language
ability, arithmetic.
With every single
test, Eliot passed
with flying colors, either
average or well above-average.
And yet, within weeks after
the recovery of his surgery,
he was fired from his
job, his wife left him,
and, for all intents
and purposes,
he had to be institutionalized.
He couldn't live on his own
because his behavior became
so irrational.
Now let me describe to you
what kind of irrationality
we're talking about.
Damasio describes what
Elliot did when he was
engaged in a task at his job.
He was an accountant
at the time.
And so Damasio writes,
"When the job called
for interrupting an activity
and turning to another,
he might persist
nonetheless, seemingly
losing sight of his main goal.
Or he might interrupt
the activity
he had engaged, to
turn to something
he found more captivating
at that particular moment.
The flow of work was stopped.
One might say that
the particular step
of the task at
which Elliot balked
was actually being
carried out too well,
and at the expense of
the overall purpose.
One might say that Eliot had
become irrational concerning
the larger frame of behavior."
Now, what Damasio was telling
you is a very simple example
that he gave in the
book, where Eliot
was asked to write a letter
to one of his clients.
He'd fire up the word
processor and, before he
started typing
that letter, he had
to pick just the right font.
And it took him three
hours to pick that font.
Three hours, literally.
Now, those of you who
use Microsoft Word,
I know that when
you first got it,
you did the same thing I did.
You pulled down that
font menu, and you
went through Arial, Sans
Serif, Times New Roman.
You checked out all those
fonts, but it probably
didn't take you three hours.
Moreover, it didn't take you
three hours every time you
had to write a letter.
Well, it did for Eliot
after the surgery.
Every letter he wrote took
three hours at the start
because he had to pick
just the right font.
And it didn't dawn on Damasio
until he gave Elliot one test
that he finally failed
as to what was going on.
And let me tell you
what the test was.
Psychologists
often use something
called eye-blink response rate
to measure emotional reaction.
It turns out that for
normal human beings, when
you have a strong
emotional response,
you blink your eyes a little
bit more quickly than usual.
All right?
Those of you who've ever
seen the Betty Boop cartoons
where they have a
female character trying
to flirt with somebody else,
that the way they'll indicate
flirtation is blinking their
eyes a little bit more quickly
or batting her eyelashes.
Right?
Those of you who are
serious poker players,
you'll know that
there's a poker tell,
meaning a physical
characteristic
that will signal a strong,
emotional reaction on the part
of your opponent.
And that is, when they
look at their hand,
they blink their eyes a
little bit more rapidly.
Either it's a really strong
hand or a really weak hand.
That's, by the way, why
many poker players--
they wear sunglasses
when they play.
Not to look cool but to
hide their reactions.
What they do is
they take a subject
and put them in front
of a computer screen.
Attach electrodes
to their eyelids
to measure how quickly
they're blinking their eyes,
and they show the
subject strong,
emotionally-charged images.
Things like
pornography or scenes
from Nazi concentration camps.
And when we have strong
emotional reactions,
you can measure the
increase in the rate
at which we blink our eyes.
It turns out that Elliot had
no change in his eye-blink
response rates.
None whatsoever.
And so Damasio
finally asked Elliot,
"Elliot, how do you feel?"
And Elliot said, "You
know, it's funny.
After the surgery, I
observed that the things
that I used to enjoy before
the surgery, I don't anymore.
For example, I used to like
steak dinners, red wine,
and Mozart.
And I've experienced all
of those things afterwards,
and I don't feel anything.
I know I should be
enjoying them, but I don't.
I don't feel anything.
I don't dislike it.
I just don't really enjoy it
as much as I know I should."
Now, I don't know
how many of you
have had that kind of reaction.
I have fairly recently.
My eight-year-old son and
I were at the supermarket
the other day, and I was
going by the candy aisle,
and I noticed that there were
Cracker Jacks on the shelf.
I don't know how many of
you know what they are?
Peanut-coated popcorn
candy and a prize, right?
Well, I loved Cracker Jacks
when I was eight years old.
I remember that very distinctly,
just really enjoying it.
So I decided I was going to
get some for my eight-year-old.
So I got some for him,
and I tried some as well.
And I remember thinking,
gee, I know I should really
be enjoying this, but I'm not.
It's not-- Maybe my tastes
have changed, I don't know,
but it's not nearly as wonderful
as I remembered it to be.
Imagine having that
feeling about everything.
All your fears, anxieties,
your great desires,
all of your emotions, gone.
You don't feel anything.
You sort of feel numb inside.
It turns out that
Damasio conjectured
that what we think of
as rational behavior
actually requires emotion.
In other words, you have
to be able to feel in order
to act rationally.
Now, that's really very
different from the typical kind
of impression where rationality
is at one end of the spectrum
and emotion, fear, and
greed are at the other end
of the spectrum.
This is Descartes'
perspective on the world.
This is why the book is
titled Descartes' Error.
He's arguing that
Descartes got it all wrong.
That, in fact, emotion is the
opposite side of the same coin.
If you can't feel, then
you can't be rational.
So this calls into question
what we think of as rationality.
And I'm going to beg your
indulgence for another five
minutes as I tell you more about
the neurophysiological basis
for this observation.
It turns out that the part of
the brain that they took out
from Elliot with his
tumor is the part that
was responsible for
emotional reaction.
And there have been
a number of theories
that have been developed now
about how the brain works.
So I want to describe probably
the most popular theory,
at least as of
about 10 years ago,
and you'll get a
better understanding
for what's going on.
And this is the part that I
think will change your lives.
So it turns out that the
brain, which is pictured here
in cross-section, is not
nearly the homogeneous organ
that we often take it to be.
It turns out that the
brain is comprised
of different components.
And a neuroscientist by
the name of Paul MacLean
about 10 years ago
came up with what's
now called the triune
model of the brain, which
decomposes the brain into
three separate components.
The first component is located
at the bottom of the brain.
It's also known
as the brain stem.
It's the part of
the brain that sits
on top of your
spinal cord, and all
of the nerves that go up
through your spinal cord
attaches into that brain stem.
And neuroscientists have
determined that the brain stem
is responsible for all of the,
sort of, bodily functions that
you take for granted, and
typically you cannot control,
unless you you're
a Zen Sufi master.
Things like heart
rate, breathing,
body temperature
regulation, things that we
need for basic survival.
And MacLean called the brain
stem the reptilian brain
because this is the
part of the brain
that we have in common with
virtually all vertebrates.
Reptiles, mammals,
anything with a spinal cord
will have a brain stem
sitting on top of that.
And from an evolutionary
perspective,
it is the oldest
part of the brain,
and the part that really
controls the very most
primitive functions of life.
The second part of the brain
that MacLean identified is
the middle part, known
as the mid-brain,
or what MacLean called
the mammalian brain.
This is the part of the
brain that we share only
with warm blooded
creatures, with mammals.
So reptiles don't have this.
And it's evolutionarily
somewhat later in development
than the reptilian brain.
And this part of the
brain is responsible
for emotional reaction,
for social behavior,
for fear and greed,
love, sexual attraction.
Now, you might ask, well, how
do neuroscientists know this?
Well, the way that
they've discovered this--
and it's only been over the
last couple of decades--
is they take a subject, and
they put him in an MRI machine.
All of you I think know
what an MRI is, right?
Magnetic resonance imaging.
And instead of taking a
snapshot, what neuroscientists
will do is to take a
series of snapshots
over many, many milliseconds
and eventually put together
a movie of your brain.
Now, the reason
that's interesting
is because blood contains iron,
and iron shows up on an MRI.
So when they take a
movie of your brain,
they see the blood
flowing in your brain.
And while a subject
is in there, they
will impose certain kinds
of stimuli on that subject
and see where the blood goes.
So, for example, they ask
you to lie in the magnet,
and you're lying
there, and they are
taking a movie of your brain.
And while you're lying
there peacefully,
they'll take a needle, and
they'll stab you with it.
And you go, "Ow!"
And what they'll show is
that blood flows to one very
specific region in the brain.
That region is the pain center
of the brain, or at least
that's how they identify it.
So when you feel
pain, and they'll
stab you with lots of
different parts of the body,
and they'll show that it
all leads to activation
of that little pain center.
So they'll say, fine,
pain is identified
in that particular region.
Now, the third part of
the brain, the last part
that MacLean
identified, is actually
what we think of as the brain.
It's that gray matter,
the curly coils.
It turns out that
that's not solid,
but that's like a blanket that
sits on top of the mid-brain.
And that part of the
brain is actually
unique to homo sapiens
and certain great apes.
So this is called
the hominid brain,
and, from an
evolutionary perspective,
it is the newest
part of the brain,
so it's often called the
neocortex, the newest
part of that brain.
Using MRI techniques,
neuroscientists
have been able to deduce
that this part of the brain
is responsible for language
ability, mathematical ability,
and logical deliberation.
What we think of as the higher
thought functions of humans.
It resides in that neocortex.
Now, why am I
telling you all this?
Well, because it turns out
that these three components
of the brain, they end up
working in different ways.
In fact, they have
different priorities.
What do I mean by that?
Well, let me give
you an example.
Suppose, God forbid,
you're in a car accident.
You're bleeding, and your
body starts to shut down.
You go into shock.
And, one by one, your
organs begin to fail.
Of the three components
of the brain,
which do you think
will shut down last?
Which of these three
components will shut down last?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The reptilian?
ANDREW LO: That's right.
Why?
AUDIENCE: It's responsible
for your basic functions, so--
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
Once your reptilian brain shuts
down, you know, that's bye-bye.
That's the end.
Right?
So this explains why you
can lose consciousness
but still breathe.
It's because
consciousness is seated
in the hominid brain and certain
parts of the mammalian brain.
But you don't need
to be conscious
in order to be breathing.
Your reptilian
brain controls that.
So from a priority perspective,
the most important part
of your three components
is the reptilian brain.
Now let me ask you
the next question.
Before that, of
the remaining two,
the hominid brain and the
mammalian brain, which
do you think has priority?
Which shuts down later in the
case of a car accident where
you're bleeding out?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The mammalian?
ANDREW LO: That's right.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because that's
where fight or flight is?
ANDREW LO: Fight or flight
is in the mammalian brain,
but why would you think
that that's higher priority?
AUDIENCE: 'Cause there's
certain scenarios
and you want to react
to those [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Right.
From an evolutionary
perspective,
it's probably more
important for you
to be scared and
run like hell when
you're being confronted
by a saber tooth tiger
than for you to be able to
solve differential equations.
Right?
Even if you're from MIT.
And so as a result, from
a evolutionary standpoint
and, more importantly, from
a physiological standpoint,
the mammalian brain has
priority over the hominid brain.
Now, neuroscientists
have documented
that this kind of hardwiring
is even more significant
than we had thought.
Let me explain why.
They did the
following experiment.
Take a subject.
Put him in a magnet.
And they asked the subject
to solve arithmetic problems
while they're in the magnet.
Now, you can do that because,
if you're lying down,
they have a mirror where they
project the image of a computer
screen, and your
hands are free even
though your head and
your body are not.
And so, while you're
lying down in the magnet
and you're looking
up at this mirror,
you see a computer screen.
And with your hands--
They give you a mouse,
and you can move around
and solve arithmetic
prompts on the screen
while you're in the magnet.
And arithmetic is
seated at this--
the hominid brain level.
So they can see
the blood flowing
into that part of the brain
as you solve these arithmetic
problems.
While you're doing that, the
experimenter will take a needle
and stab you with it.
And you go, "Ow!"
And then it takes you longer
to solve those arithmetic
problems.
Now you're saying, this is
what they give grants for?
I mean, anybody can tell
you that when somebody's
trying to stab you, it's
going to take you longer
to solve arithmetic problems.
OK.
But here's the insight.
The insight is that
what they discovered
was that the flow of blood was
constricted to your neocortex
after that pain that
was implemented,
but it lasted for hours.
The restriction of blood
flow to your neocortex
lasted for hours
after that pinprick.
Not just seconds, not just
minutes, but hours afterward,
it took you longer to
solve arithmetic problems.
For all intents and
purposes, that pain stimulus
made you stupider
for a period of time.
You physiologically could
not solve those problems
as quickly as before.
And this is a stunning
result. Because what it says
is that there are periods
where, for purely physiological
reasons, we are going to
be inhibited from using
that part of the brain.
I'm going to give you
some examples of this
in your own behavior,
just to prove
to you that this is
actually going on right now
in your heads.
How many of you have had
the following experience?
You're trying to meet a
very attractive individual.
You want to go out
on a date with them.
So you think of all sorts
of really clever ways
of meeting them by accident.
And then, when you
do that, you're
going to ask them out on a date.
And you've got your
lines prepared.
You know exactly
what you're going
to say to make them
just completely
thrilled at going out with you.
And finally, it
starts to unfold.
It happens.
You meet the person and, as
soon as you open your mouth,
and you start talking, you
sound like a total idiot.
You say all the
wrong things, right?
You're tongue tied,
you start stuttering.
And there's a reason for this.
There's a physiological reason.
You know what it is?
It's the fact that sexual
attraction hyperstimulates
your mid-brain, here.
And when it does, it
restricts your blood flow
to the neocortex.
Language ability is
in the neocortex.
Love makes you stupid.
Let me give you another example.
This is an example that we're
going to do together, OK?
The example is going
to go like this.
I'm going to show
you a bunch of words
that have different colors.
And I don't want you
to read anything,
but I want you to say out loud
with me what the colors are,
from left to right.
OK?
So these are the words.
But we're going to say out
loud together, as quickly
as possible, the colors.
You guys ready?
OK, here we go.
Red, green, blue, yellow,
orange, blue, brown, red,
green, purple, pink,
black, blue, yellow, green.
No problem, right?
Very easy.
We do the exact same
thing now with this.
Say the colors as
quickly as possible.
You ready?
OK, here we go.
Blue, red, blue, black, orange--
[LAUGHTER]
What happened?
What's going on?
Couldn't do it as
quickly, could you?
Well, let me tell
you what's going on.
It turns out that language
ability and color recognition
are actually handled by two
different parts of the brain.
Language ability
resides strictly
in the neocortex,
the hominid brain.
But color recognition
is actually
part of the mammalian brain.
Mammals can recognize
colors very well.
In fact, I don't
know how many of you
have redecorated your homes, or
your kitchens, or dining rooms,
recently.
I did this a couple
of years ago.
And my wife talked
to one of her friends
who is a decorator
who told her, you've
got to paint your
dining room in red.
Because-- Why?
Anybody know?
Why is red the preferred color
of restaurants, dining rooms?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Makes you eat more.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
Makes you eat more.
It's a more appetizing color.
Anybody ever wonder why that is?
Do you know why red is
a more appetizing color?
I hate to tell you because you
may not be appetized anymore.
AUDIENCE: Because of the color?
ANDREW LO: It's
the color of blood.
Because it's hardwired into us.
When we see blood,
it's dinnertime.
[LAUGHTER]
And that is hardwired.
It's true.
I mean, I don't know how
many of you have ever
gone to The Blue Room.
That's a restaurant
down the street.
I've actually never
been there, and I
have to confess the
reason is that the idea
of a blue room for dinner is
not very appetizing to me.
Blue is not a color you
want to see in your food.
So color recognition
is a deep-seated part
of our mammalian brain.
But language ability is not.
Language ability is a
different part of the brain.
In this case, where the colors
and the words don't match,
it takes your brain
a split second longer
to adjudicate that conflict.
But in this case,
when they're the same,
you can rattle it off like this.
[SNAPS FINGERS]
So let me bring this
now all back to finance,
as I told you I would.
What's the point of all this?
The point is that
what we take to be
human preferences
for decision-making
is not a mathematical,
immutable object.
But, in fact, preferences
are the outcome
of interactions between
the mammalian brain
and the hominid brain.
And what we think of as
basic decision-making
requires the proper
balance of the two.
So, in other words, rationality
is not logical deliberation.
The patient, Elliot, was
a clear counterexample.
Elliot was very logical,
but he was not rational.
Emotion is a critical
component of rationality.
But too much emotion,
and you get stupid,
as the case with falling
in love or in the case
of overwhelming
emotional stimulus
cutting off blood flow
to your neocortex.
This, by the way, will lead to
some very useful self-help kind
of advice.
Let me give you an example.
Those of you who've ever been
involved in corporate politics,
back office politics--
one of the things that
you should keep in mind
is that, when you are
emotionally hyper-stimulated,
you will not be able
to think straight.
How many of you've ever heard
the phrase, I was so angry,
I could barely speak?
You've heard that, right?
You've probably felt that.
Well, that's not
just a metaphor.
That's actual
physiologically true.
When you are so angry, it
will cut off the flow of blood
to your neocortex, and you
will not be able to speak.
You will not be able to express
yourself as articulately.
So the next time somebody
goes into your office,
or your cubicle,
or your company,
and says something to
you that makes you so mad
that you want to strangle
them, and you can't speak,
the best thing to
do is not to speak.
It's to say, "Thank
you very much.
That was very insightful.
Let me get back to
you in a week or so."
Because if you try to talk
when you are emotionally
hyper-stimulated,
you will undoubtedly
say stupid things,
things you will regret
for possibly years later.
And this is a direct outcome
of this neurophysiological
research.
Our preferences are the sum
total of these interactions.
Therefore, they are
not stable over time,
nor are they stable
over circumstances.
All right?
You are not the same person
that you were 10 years ago.
And many of you who are going
to be facing losses of one kind
or another-- you lose a parent,
you lose a spouse or child--
you will not be the same person
after that event as before.
It will change you
because it will
change the balance
between your hominid brain
and your mammalian brain.
And unless you bring
those back into balance,
you're going to be making
decisions differently.
So if there's any
advice that I have
for you about how to take
this information and use it,
it's to keep your
eyes on the objective.
In other words, decide what you
want to achieve and then ask
yourself at every
step of the way,
"Is my current actions
about to help or hinder
those objectives?"
You know, if you're driving
home from work one day,
and somebody cuts
you off, and you
want to give them the finger
and ram your car into them,
ask yourself, will
that help you achieve
your objective of getting home
without an incident or not?
If it doesn't, you
probably shouldn't do it,
even though it'd feel
really good to do that.
OK?
Now, let me tell you about the
adaptive markets hypothesis
and how I'm going to put
it all together for you.
Behavioral finance
and rational finance.
They are both correct, and
they're both incorrect.
The reason that
they're both correct
is that they both apply
to certain circumstances.
What I taught you in
this course up until now,
what we've learned together,
is the rational finance
that applies most
of the time when
your mid-brain
and your neocortex
are properly balanced.
But during extreme
periods of distress,
when you are emotionally
either overwhelmed positive
or overwhelmed negative, in
either of those circumstances,
you will not behave in ways
that we would consider rational.
Those are the moments when
behavioral finance applies
or, at least, when
the anomalies arise.
Behavioral finance
is not a theory,
it's simply a
collection of anomalies.
The adaptive markets
hypothesis is this theory
that I've been developing for
the last several years that
tries to put these two together.
And the way to do
that is by recognizing
that we are both creatures
of our mammalian brain
and creatures of our neocortex.
Depending on market conditions,
environmental conditions,
and our own
decision-making process,
we may or may not be
in the rational camp
or the behaviorial camp
at any point in time.
And when you look at the
market as a whole, an aggregate
over all of these
individuals, you
will be able to get a
sense of whether or not
you can trust market prices.
At the beginning of the course,
as this crisis was unfolding,
I told you very clearly
that finance theory
is going to be taking a
several week vacation.
What I was getting at is
that, right now, all of us
are being hyper-stimulated
in our mid-brain.
We are all scared to death as to
what we're going to read about.
There was a time during
this course where
I was really not looking
forward to the weekends
because something always seemed
to be going on on the weekends.
And Monday I'd have to tell you,
well, gee, this bank is gone,
and that investment
bank is no more.
And it was a very
stressful period.
It still is.
Decision-making is going
to be affected by that.
So we developed
heuristics, rules of thumb,
to balance out our neocortex
and our mammalian brain.
We come up with, not
theoretical optimum optimization
algorithms, but we come
up with rules of thumb.
And the idea behind the
adaptive markets hypothesis
is that these rules of thumb
evolve over time as they either
succeed or they fail.
So the economics that we
learn and teach you in class
is meant to be an approximation
to a much more complex reality.
Sometimes that
approximation works,
sometimes it doesn't,
and the only way
to really understand
which it is,
is to try to get a sense of
how this evolutionary process
works.
In particular, where do
these various different kinds
of rules of thumb come from?
And to do that, I want to
tell you about one last thing,
and then we're
going to conclude,
which is that evolutionary
forces are really
what drives the
success or failure
of these rules of thumb.
And I want to give you an
example of these kinds of rules
of thumb and how
adaptation works.
And to do that, I'm
going to tell you
about a personal example
that has to do with a problem
that I solve every day.
And it's a problem that
I think you have as well.
I'm going to tell you about
how my heuristic developed
over the years.
The problem that I'm
going to talk about
is the problem of getting
dressed in the morning.
OK?
Every morning, all of
us have to get dressed.
And to give you a
sense of the challenges
that I face in my process
of getting dressed,
I have to tell you
about my wardrobe.
So here's my wardrobe.
I've got five jackets,
10 pairs of pants,
20 ties, 10 shirts, 10 pairs
of socks, four pairs of shoes,
and five belts.
Now, you might argue that's
a rather limited wardrobe.
However, if you took the time
to compute the combinatorics,
you would see that I have
two million unique outfits
in my wardrobe.
Now, granted, not all of
them are of the same fashion
content.
They're not all
equally compelling
from the fashion
perspective, so I've
got an optimization problem.
I've got to figure out
which is the right outfit
for the right occasion.
Suppose it takes me one
second to evaluate the fashion
content of an outfit.
How long would it take me
to get dressed every day?
Well, you do the math.
Turns out that it would take
me 23.1 days to get dressed.
Now, clearly, I don't take
that long to get dressed,
so how do I do it?
Do I have some superhuman
optimization algorithm up
my sleeve?
No.
It turns out I use a
heuristic, a rule of thumb.
And you might say, well, where
did you get that rule of thumb?
I'll tell you.
When I was six years old,
growing up in Queens,
New York, at that time
the superhero of the day
was Superman.
Everybody watched Superman on
TV, comic books, and so on.
And some clever marketing
genius figured out
that if you put a Superman
emblem on a jacket,
you could sell a lot of
them to six-year-old kids.
And growing up in a
single parent household,
we didn't have a
lot of extra cash,
so it took me weeks to nag my
mother to get me this jacket.
Weeks and weeks
of daily nagging.
And finally, after
weeks of nagging,
she relented, and she agreed
to buy me this jacket.
And I remember
vividly, you know,
Friday afternoon after school,
she got home from work.
I waited for her, we went to
Alexander's, bought the jacket.
I spent the whole weekend
wearing this thing, day
and night.
It was wonderful.
And Monday morning, I got up
extra early, really excited
to go to school
with this jacket.
I looked in the mirror,
did all my action poses
and looked at myself.
And by the time I
was done with that,
I was 15 minutes
late for school,
and I needed a note from my
mother to get into class.
And I remember vividly,
walking into the classroom,
going up to the
front of the room,
giving the teacher
the note, walking back
to my seat, all the other
kids already sitting down,
reading, snickering at me.
And I was completely mortified.
And you know I must be mortified
because, 42 years later, I
still remember this exactly.
And you know what?
From that day on, it never
took me more than five minutes
to get dressed.
Ever.
Never.
So I solved my problem
based upon very strong,
negative feedback.
You see how it works?
I have a new heuristic for
getting dressed in the morning,
but that new heuristic only
came about after some very
strong, negative emotion.
If I was like
Elliot, and I never
had any negative
feedback, I'd go
on taking hours to get
dressed every morning
instead of getting dressed in
five minutes, like I do now.
Now, somebody else, let's say
a movie star like Tom Cruise.
I suspect that Tom Cruise spends
a lot more than five minutes
getting dressed in the morning.
In fact, he probably spends
more time coiffing his hair
than I spend coiffing my hair.
And there's a reason for that.
For him, it makes sense.
That heuristic for him
makes sense in his context,
not in my context.
All of us, we engage
in these heuristics
that are adaptive to the
particular situation at hand.
So the adaptive
markets hypothesis
acknowledges that
people make mistakes,
but they learn, and
they adapt, assuming
there's balance between emotion
and logical deliberation.
So there are a number of
very practical implications
for this, some of which
suggest that the CAPM does not
work and should not work,
except during certain periods
of the market.
So what we've learned
together in this course
describes 80% to 90% of
what happens in markets.
But there's another 10% or 20%
of extreme and unusual market
conditions that makes this field
a lot more challenging than you
might otherwise think.
And that's the part that I
want you to keep in mind.
We're not going to talk about
that anymore in this course,
or in 402, or in 433,
or in 434, or 437.
We don't talk about the
messy part of finance
because it's still
currently being developed.
In fact, as I told you
at the very beginning,
you're not going to
find any textbook
versions of the adaptive
markets hypothesis.
The only person you'll
ever find talking about it
right now is me, unfortunately.
Hopefully, that will
change over time,
but this is still
under development.
But just keep in mind that the
theories that you've learned
apply not all of the time.
Most of the time, they
apply and they're useful,
but they are an approximation
to a much more complex reality.
And that reality
will incorporate
lots of other phenomenon
which we described here
and which I'll talk a
bit more about on Monday.
OK.
So let me stop here since
we're just about out of time.
Any questions?
No?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering if
you might think, for example,
if I have an exam,
I tend to notice
that I will be way more
productive at learning way
before two days before.
And I cannot see a conflict
because I was feeling
the pressure in
handling my emotions.
But how is it possible that
I feel the emotion but,
at the same time, I--
ANDREW LO: That is a
fantastic question.
Let me repeat the question.
I'm not going to
answer today, but I'm
going to talk about it
on Monday, because it's
both a great question in
the context of this theory,
but it's also very
apropos, so I'm
going to be talking about
the final exam next Monday.
OK?
The question is, when you
were studying for an exam,
you're under pressure.
You're feeling a lot
of emotional stress,
and yet you seem to
learn better, faster,
during those periods of time.
It turns out that there is a
physiological and psychological
basis when a certain
amount of pressure
is actually a good thing.
But the question is, what
is that certain amount?
Any more than that, and
then you'd be a basket case.
So we're going to talk
about that on Monday.
All right?
Thanks.